Hi, my name is Helen Zhou,
and the goal of my project
is to predict
antibiotic resistance.
Antibiotic resistance
is a major problem.
It's responsible for 23,000
annual deaths in the United
States alone, and 700,000
annual deaths worldwide.
One of the leading causes
of antibiotic resistance
is the overprescription of
overly broad antibiotics.
This motivates the
focus of our project,
which is in the empiric
antibiotic treatment setting.
In this setting, a patient
comes in with an infection
and the doctor needs to
make an immediate treatment
decision before the
patient is sent home.
They have to do this using
only the information that's
available to them at
the time, and they
want to prescribe something
that is both effective
and doesn't have too
many negative side
effects for both the
individual and the population.
However, they're missing a
critical piece of information
at this point in time,
and that's precisely what
is the patient resistant to.
And so since this
is so important,
we want to predict resistance
at an individual level
at the point of care.
We do this by using
machine learning models
to combine information
from many modalities,
such as natural language
clinician's notes, diagnoses,
procedures, lab values.
And we do this for 275,000
patients from the Brigham
and MGH across
more than 17 years.
As far as we know, this is at a
larger scale and broader scope
than previous work, and we're
able to do these predictions
quite well.
So in the future,
we hope that we'll
be able to provide these
accurate predictions that
are also timely to
doctors so that they
can provide the best care that
they can for their patients.